what we really enjoyed was you know we
received this email from you rafal that
your campaign is not live yet it's in
sort of beta mode and um you showed us
the
um the beautiful kickstarter video
what was your plan you said you've been
making this well actually you know i i
didn't really have a sort of plan i mean
i've been working on this kickstarter
campaign for actually two years
uh it it just has evolved you know
and each time i get i'm ready to send it
out and i've been ready a couple of
times before even a year ago i just get
nervous and scared and i redo it
and so it's really been evolving like
soup you know and they say the longer
the soup cooks you know the better it
becomes so i hope i hope it works you
know and and you know it's been a
process i mean first it started with
getting an artist to do to convey the
beauty and the power of the script in 12
drawings that was my mission you know
and that took half a year i mean i
reached out to so many graphic artists
illustrators you know in london in
england in in in canada and like
everyone some they kept on falling
through and then finally you know my
wife had a few days off at work and she
just rolled up her sleeves and
she just loved these characters and she
just drew these 12 drawings they're so
beautiful and that was the first step
you know and um
you know i mean i'm so grateful to her
because she saved us you know and she
really spent so much love and attention
into these characters she really found
casey you know and samuel in these
drawings
and and in every pencil stroke you feel
the emotion so that was the first step
then the next step is let's now get
actors who will
you know read the script because it
would be beautiful to have readings of
the script with drawings behind
and once again we started reaching out
and finding actors and
finally i was at the soccer game and i
met carmen cuba who is steve sodenberg's
you know casting director and i told him
i need to find a wonderful like 14 year
old actress and she says you know i just
finished this film with steve and he
found this girl that he loves
anna anna jacob herron you know and she
put us in touch with her and
she was just she was just amazing you
know she came in and i found this
wonderful old theater actor who's like
in his 90s
you know who could like
who was the samuel and we got them in
the studio and he was just beautiful
like it all came alive you know
gina was there yeah it was it was really
nice did the readings so then we had
these drawings and these readings and
then you know i felt you know this this
needs some life so i said let's start
interviewing
people on the theme of this film so i
reached out to a i went to the museum of
tolerance at the simon wiesenthal center
and i there was a presentation which was
about
various religions combined coming
together
and there was this wonderful rabbi rabbi
adelstein you know who i approached and
i said let's do an interview about
forgiveness read the script what do you
think you know this is a very
complicated issue because in a way
samuel forgives through forgiving this
girl and her blindness he's in a way
forgiving the past
and you know and some people
misinterpreted is he like for giving the
holocaust you know which he's not it's a
personal forgiveness but then it created
a really interesting discussion so um
he did a really wonderful talk about
forgiveness
and how it applies to this script and
then he said you know you got to get
this
this islamic this muslim professor you
need to get this buddhist
you know
um you got you have to get this priest
you have to reach out
and he gave me names of people to
approach and they we interviewed them
all about the themes in this movie
and then out of that we said you know
let's just go out in the streets let's
hit the streets of new york let's hit
the streets of l.a and let's talk to
people what is world peace what is
forgiveness what is
you know the themes of this movie and we
just got all these amazing answers
so then that's how this whole
presentation came about it just evolved
and then you know we put it all together
and
here it is you know but the energy the
thing we captured in the you know what
some of these speakers said what the
public said
you know in a way it's sort of like
coming into the subtext of the script
you know it was all there in the
beginning in gina's script but somehow
it to me it all came alive
and you know that energy of this cheat
is what i really want to capture in this
film
and it's part of my process did you then
show the the finished kickstarter video
to various people like you reached out
to us and said you know this will be
launching on this date just you know
want to put some feelers out did you get
feedback from people he did i wasn't
involved at all
i had nothing to do with it i i just
showed it to a few select friends you
know i was very very cautious about
sending it and you know a lot of people
were you know i got a lot of good
critiques you know about it you know
what they said
well you know some of the um
you know it's um what what were some of
the rights
to wait too long always that's the
problem you know people have such as
short as attention span you got to sell
this thing in two minutes you know i
just can't do it i just can't do it
i mean this video is probably the
longest video out there on kickstarter
but i don't care i just feel it just
conveys the the journey and the emotion
and you know and it's designed i hope in
a way where after two minutes people can
get it and if they don't want to watch
the whole thing they can just stop
and still
you know get what the whole story is
about
you know so basically we reached out to
a few select people and then about um
you know two weeks before presenting it
we tried to reach out to bloggers and to
press as much as we could in our own
you know humble way without a publicist
so we try to find them on linkedin on
other blogs and we try to
to build up
but i'm told that i didn't do it the
right way you know i'm told that i
should have had a million twitter
followers already before i launched you
know but do tell i want to hear what
what advice did people give you
what did you say well i'm just going to
throw caution to the wind you know it
seems that to have a successful
kickstarter campaign you need like
either a celebrity or
some kind of a huge
network some foundation that's already
behind you right from the beginning
and you know i don't think we i had that
and i don't think i have that but i'm
building it slowly as we go along and
that's why you know we're going for a
longer campaign of 60 days usually they
recommend just do it in 30 days you know
or you'll get people really upset or
you know but i'm using it the first half
of this campaign is a way to slowly to
reach out and let the
you know peop more and more people know
about it and hopefully the second half
will be the real campaign
so then how much did you follow up with
individuals once you reached out to
those bloggers i know it's only been a
few weeks but you know what uh
i don't think we did or maybe we might
have sent a follow-up message um
but we didn't we just you know put it
out there
and um
you know
and i think what we desperately need now
i think is someone with a big following
who just like endorsed you know this
thing i mean i wrote letters i wrote a
letter to steven spielberg i wrote
letters you know to every star i could
think of that i might have had any type
of tiny little interaction with and i'm
just praying that you know one of them
will see it and
you know champion this film and say hey
support this film it's a beautiful
project
i'm hoping that maybe stephen will
because
martin landa who was attached to this
project um
a little while ago when we were sitting
with martin um
he read me a letter that stephen had
written that he had sent because martin
had sent the script to him and
he wrote stephen wrote this beautiful
letter saying how
much he believed in the script and and
its power and his message and he was so
encouraging to martin to you know
whatever i can do to help so i hope that
maybe he'll remember and somehow it'll
trigger his
you know memory and he will
come to us somehow you know
in planning out the campaign did you
realize how much time per day like
sometimes i think people don't realize
it is it's like having a job like it's
yeah that's a big job for two years i
know it really is you know i mean every
day
i mean it was a huge job creating all
the video materials you know that that
was hugely consuming because not only
did we did the kickstarter video but we
did maybe two or three hundred all kinds
of little videos of people in the
streets and discussions and this and
that and we're you know putting them out
throughout the campaign so just trying
to get all these videos together was a
huge job but not only that just trying
to present yourself to the world as a
director so not only they had to create
this campaign but i had to create
websites for all my past movies and
create blogs and and like create music
marketing yeah i mean i really had to
spend like while i was presenting this
film i was trying to present myself to
the social you know to the internet
because all and i noticed that you know
what was on the web before it began was
like totally wrong like
you know people only remembered me from
a couple of roger carmen movies which
i'm so embarrassed about you know having
even done
and no one seemed to have even known
about my sundance movies or the art
films so i had to like rebuild myself
so between the kickstarter campaign and
rebuilding myself that was like two
years of work
and now it's like a huge job just to run
this campaign and i have a couple of
wonderful interns and friends and
volunteers who encourage me and help and
and i really thank them for this you
know
and
you know and the other thing which i'm
very fortunate about is that um
you know claire boucher grimes that i
just love her music i approached her
like three years ago when she was
totally unknown
i told her about this project and she
was so gracious in saying you know
just use my music in your trailers and
see what you know whatever whatever i
can do to help so it's beautiful i'm so
grateful you know to her because if her
music really makes this presentation
come alive and
and i'm praying that maybe she will do
the music for the film you know she's
become very well known now and i'm sure
everyone
is after her
but i i
hope that indeed i mean he always has an
eye for talent yeah that she will do the
soundtrack because i think she's
incredible i think she's just an amazing
talent
you